[MUSIC PLAYING]
HODIE MEYERS: Hey, everyone.
We're really excited
to have you at Next.
I'm Hodie Meyers, Project
Manager on Drive Platform.
STEVE BAZYL: And I'm Steve
Basil, Developer Programs
Engineer for G Suite APIs.
HODIE MEYERS: And
we're here today
to talk about something that
every enterprise is facing.
You'll always be growing your
wings, getting new people up
and productive.
New team members need to get
access to all the existing
files, and when
people leave, you
want all their
work to disappear.
The faster and smoother
you can achieve
this, the faster you get
employees up and productive.
STEVE BAZYL: And that's
why we created Team Drives.
Team Drives extends Drive with
safe, easy-to-manage shared
spaces for teams.
And starting today,
Team Drives is supported
by the Google Drive API.
We have a couple of
our partners here today
to talk about what they're
doing with that API
to help teams work
better together.
HODIE MEYERS: In enterprise
and large organizations,
the needs for drive
and drive apps
have evolved over
the last years.
Most work is done in groups.
When Drive and the Drive API
were originally designed,
the vision was on a
single user sharing files
on a one-off basis, all the
file ownership permissions
and engineering
optimizations were
centered on this one use case.
So as a result, you could
get into confusing states
when you're
collaborating on files,
such as different people
having different views
on the same folder.
For example, I shared the
presentation folder with Steve,
I had some files
in there for him.
But I didn't realize
those files had
more restrictive permissions
than the folder itself.
So Steve never even saw that
these files were in there,
and I didn't realize he didn't
see them until he asked me
for them weeks later.
Team Drives is addressing this.
The Team Drive looks the same
to everyone in the Team Drive.
It's extremely
important to make sure
that all your team members have
access to all the information
they need.
STEVE BAZYL: So let's
talk a little bit more
about that concretely.
To ensure that
everyone in the team
gets a consistent view of
all the items in there,
we had to make some changes
to the permission model
and the organization model.
So one of the more
notable changes
is a file can exist in either
my Drive or Team Drives,
but not both.
When a file is in
Team Drives, it's
owned by the team itself,
not any individual user, not
the person who created the file.
Those files also have a very
consistent location as files
and Team Drives could
only ever have one parent.
So everybody knows where
every file is and they see
all files in the same place.
To ensure that everyone
has a consistent view,
everyone who's a member of the
Team Drive can see all items.
They may not all be able
to write those items.
It just depends on the role.
And one of the things
we've heard a lot
is people getting confused
when somebody deletes or moves
a file that's in
a shared folder,
and they don't realize that
somebody is using that file.
And all of a sudden,
all these other users
don't know what happened.
In Team Drives, we made
moving and deleting
a lot more restricted.
We created a new role
called Organizer,
and Organizers are the only
members of the Team Drive
that can actually move
or delete content.
HODIE MEYERS: But
sometimes you don't
want to add people
to your Team Drive,
but you still want
to give them access
to individual files
within the Team Drive.
For example, we created a
video demoing Team Drives.
When we wanted to share with
folks among the company,
we didn't want to add
them to our Team Drive.
They were not part of our
team and all the internal docs
were of no relevance to them.
We just wanted to give them
access to this one file.
So in addition to
Team Drive membership,
we have the concept
of file access,
giving users access
to individual files
within the Team Drive
without sharing anything
about the Team Drive itself.
So when people saw the video of
our demo, they saw the video,
but they did not see any
information on our Team Drive
name, the people
in the Team Drive,
or the Team Drive folder
structure, because none of that
was relevant to them.
So none of that was shared.
And finally, the old drive
model could get confusing.
When you were collaborating
on the same file
and different people had the
same file on different folders.
Let's say I had
this presentation
in my Presentations
folder and Steve had it
in his Next folder.
If Steve was sharing
his Next folder with me,
I would have the same file
in two different places,
getting confused over which
one is the real one or are they
duplicates or copies.
To make collaboration
less confusing,
Team Drive files have
exactly one parent.
That means that
every Team Drive file
belongs to a single Team
Drive and a single location
within this Team Drive.
STEVE BAZYL: All of
these changes change
how the Drive API
works with Team Drives.
To avoid breaking applications,
we took an opt-in approach.
That means if you want to
work with content in Drive
or manage Team
Drives themselves,
you need to make changes
to your application.
If you don't, your
app won't break,
you just won't be able
to access that content.
Before you begin though,
be aware that Team Drives
is only available for G Suite
Business and Enterprise.
In order to play
with Team Drives,
learn about the features,
and experiment with the API,
you'll need to have a domain
with either of those additions
in order to try
these features out.
That said, the opt-in
approach starts
with including an
extra query parameter
in most of your API calls.
And this is appropriately
named supportsTeamDrives
and you set it to true.
This is an acknowledgement
to us that your application
is ready to handle some of
the behavioral differences
that you'll experience with
content in Team Drives.
Of course, your
application needs
to be able to handle
those differences.
And this includes things
such as response fields that
aren't populated on
Team Drive content,
the awareness of new roles,
like Organizer, and restrictions
on operations such as setting
[? parenths ?] so that you
can only have one
inside a Team Drive.
If you don't set
this parameter, we'll
just pretend that the files
that you're asking for
or any files in Team
Drive don't exist.
And if you try to get
it, you will get a 404,
just like any other file that
you don't have access to.
This, of course, is really
just the tip of the iceberg
and a bit of an
oversimplification.
Fortunately, though,
many apps won't
need to do much more than this.
In fact, I was
just playing around
with one of our
sample applications.
It was a simple text editor that
we had built a couple of years
ago, and literally the changes
were about three lines of code.
So in that case, it
was very, very simple
for me to support Team Drives.
For other applications
though, the changes
can get complicated
pretty quickly.
If you deal a lot
with permissions,
change logs, or do a lot
of file organization,
you're likely going to have
a lot more changes to think
about.
We created a guide
in our documentation
that details all the behavioral
changes that you'll experience
with the Drive API so
you can plan your work
and assess the
impact appropriately.
HODIE MEYERS: So
far, we've told you
a lot about what we've
built. But you're probably
really interested in what
you can do with this building
and how you can fill it.
So for the Team
Drives launch, we've
worked with our top
partners to make sure
that Team Drives API
is working for them
and that their
apps are supporting
Team Drives at launch.
We have five partners
here with us today
to tell us all about how they've
made use of the Team Drives API
and maybe share some
tricks what they've
learned working with it.
First, we have Paul
Lees from CloudMigrator.
PAUL LEES: Hi, my
name is Paul Lees
and I'm the co-founder and CTO
of Cloud Technology Solutions,
and we're the developers
of the CloudMigrator.
CloudMigrator is the world's
leading migration platform
for Google G Suite.
We've helped organizations
migrate emails, calendars,
contacts, and files to the
Google G Suite environment.
We've moved over 5.5
million individuals
and over 3 petabytes of data.
And now we're helping
organizations move files
from systems such Box,
Dropbox, OneDrive, SharePoint,
local file systems,
and even Google Drive
shared folders to Team Drive.
We've been working with the
Google APIs for many years
and we've been involved
in some of the largest
migrations to date.
So for us, like Steve
mentioned, moving to Team
Drives was a fairly
trivial task.
However, I'd like to
focus more on what
we've done with one
of our customers
that we've helped to
move to Team Drives.
Let me introduce you to Veolia.
Veolia is a large organization.
They specialize in
water, waste management,
and energy services.
Veolia have over 170,000
employees around the world.
115,000 of those have
a G Suite account.
Veolia moved to
Google back in 2013,
and they have a very
well-established Google
environment and ecosystem.
Veolia have made extensive
use of Google Drive
with over 18
million files shared
inside their organization.
Collaboration has always
been key to the way
that Veolia work.
Individuals get together to
form ad hoc groups, growing
and shrinking as
the need requires.
These teams have utilized
Google Drive and Google Docs.
However, Veolia have started to
experience some of the issues
that Hodie mentioned around
file inconsistencies.
And specifically offboarding
uses, where a manual process
will have to be
performed in order
to transfer ownership
of files for users
who are being offboarded.
So the release of Team Drives
and the move to Team Drives
was absolutely
critical for Veolia.
So working with the global
IS&T team of Veolia,
we set about implementing
a Team Drives pilot.
Using the CloudMigrator,
we analyzed
existing Google shared folders.
First, we had to identify
the most appropriate users
inside these shared
folders to make sure
that they would be able to
benefit from collaborating
inside a Team Drive.
We then needed to get a
360 degree view of the file
sharing inside these folders.
We needed to make sure that
every user had the same view
of these file shares.
We also needed to
make sure there
wasn't any accidental
sharing permissions.
Maybe those didn't need
to be passed over when
we moved to Team Drives.
Could the users
see the same files?
And because when you're using
the API you're migrating
or you're focusing
on a specific user,
you're performing a
migration as a user,
we need to identify
which user we need to do
the migration on behalf of.
Because if we perform the
migration for somebody
who doesn't have access
to all of the files,
then we're going to
miss some of that data.
So again, the analytics
is key to how that works.
So the result, seamless
integration and migration
with CloudMigrator.
The users can now
work on existing files
while still taking
advantage of Team Drives.
And while this event is really
a technology conference,
it's important to understand
the impact that we can have
to users on their daily lives.
So I'm going to leave you with
a statement from the Veolia CTO
and on why he feels Team
Drive is so important.
STEVE BAZYL: Thanks and thanks
for making it so much easier
to migrate to Team Drives.
[APPLAUSE]
HODIE MEYERS: Thank you.
And next up is Nate
Collum from BetterCloud.
[APPLAUSE]
NATE COLLUM: If I can figure
out how to make this work.
OK, great.
Thank you, Hodie.
I'm very excited to be at
Next and to share with you how
BetterCloud will support the
management and adoption of Team
Drive for your organization.
BetterCloud is the first
ever unified SaaS management
platform, enabling IT
to centralize, automate,
and govern users and data across
all of their SaaS environments.
Let me talk a little bit
about how we do that.
As a SaaS-powered organization
grows in SaaS app adoption
and users, manual
administration for these users
inside these native
admin consoles
becomes an unscalable
burden for IT,
and it also creates a security
risk for your organization.
BetterCloud centralizes
the functions
available in these
disparate SaaS admin
consoles into a single
point of control.
BetterCloud connects directly
to your SaaS applications APIs
and ingests information
about your organization
and then we normalize that
data into buckets, like users,
and groups, and
data, and resources.
And we present
those in data grids,
and reporting, and
alerts, and insights.
And we allow you to take
action on those data objects,
individual or one-off,
and of course we
give you the ability to
create automated workflows
to streamline management
for these SaaS apps.
Again, all from a
single interface.
BetterCloud is all in
when it comes to Google.
We're the number one admin app
on the G Suite marketplace.
Since our inception over
the last five years,
we've served over 3,000
customers with 4 million users.
Our product is built completely
on the Google Cloud Platform
and we integrate with
the entire G Suite stack
to provide a seamless
management experience
for IT professionals.
So we remain fully committed
to supporting G Suite
and, of course, Team Drive.
So let's very quickly
talk about the problem.
We're hearing more and
more that IT professionals
are experiencing what they've
dubbed death by 1,000 tabs.
Day to day, a SaaS management
of simple user changes,
password changes, group
membership updates, or even
the more complex tasks, like
onboarding and offboarding.
These tasks are manual,
repetitive, tedious,
and, of course, they're
prone to human error.
And in some cases,
slow to resolve.
So with BetterCloud, IT
admins can take action
across their SaaS apps,
one-off or in bulk,
and with BetterCloud
Workflows, they
can easily automate custom
sequences that match
their existing manual process.
We've built this using a
[? when/if/then ?] engine.
Let me show you what it
looks like for Team Drive.
So here the IT admin is
building an onboarding workflow
for their sales department.
So when a new sales rep or
when a new user is created
and they're added to
the sales org unit,
we're going to automate
a number of onboarding
related activities
for that user.
Things like adding them
to the right groups,
sharing the right
calendars, and of course,
adding them to the
sales Team Drive.
Now this completely
automates the process
of onboarding a user
into Team Drive,
but it also makes
sure that that user
has the access to everything
they need on day one.
And as you can see,
it's incredibly easy
to onboard your
users to Team Drive.
Another thing that we
see a lot, team changes.
Now let's say we
want to automate
the process of a user moving
from one team to another team.
In this example, the user is
moving from the sales team
to the support team, and
this workflow completely
automates removing them
from the sales Team Drive
and adding them to the
support Team Drive.
In addition to
this, it also adds
them to support related
items and removes them
from sales related items, like
Slack channels or Slack user
groups.
And as you guys will see
later in this presentation,
Slack has an amazing
Team Drive integration.
And finally, these
actions can also
be taken one-off or in bulk.
What we're looking at now
is the directory user grid
in BetterCloud.
I can filter by the
Department field in Google,
search specifically for sales,
and then via our action engine,
add them directly to Team Drive.
To summarize,
BetterCloud empowers
IT to take action and
orchestrate complex processes
across your applications,
users, and data,
while ensuring accuracy,
precision, and compliance.
Every day, thousands
of customers
rely on BetterCloud to
centralize data and controls,
surface operational
intelligence,
and orchestrate complex
actions across all their SaaS
applications.
And now you can too
with Team Drive.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
STEVE BAZYL: Thanks, Nate.
A hot topic in cybersecurity
is user and entity behavior
analytics.
To talk about how
CloudLock is supporting
Team Drives and their products
is Hayley Bakst from Cisco.
[APPLAUSE]
HAYLEY BAKST: So the way we work
has changed over the past 10
years.
With the advent of
cloud and mobile,
more and more
people are not bound
by the four corners of
going to a company every day
and working there.
So with that,
security has obviously
had to have to change.
Let's talk a little
bit about why.
We have IaaS, PaaS,
and SaaS applications
more readily available.
And we're going to
these applications
because they enhance
our productivity,
they're more cost
effective, but also we
have our on-premise data
moving to the public cloud,
critical data moving
to the public cloud.
The second thing is
with coffee shop IT.
We're no longer having
to work in the office
and log on to the VPN.
This can leave us a little bit
more vulnerable to attacks,
and companies can lack that
visibility and protection.
And the third thing is with
bring-your-own-device and then
turn out of things, there's
more unmanaged devices going
on your network.
So with CloudLock, it's
a new security vector
that has been established
because of these things.
Our concern now is what
data is in the cloud, who
is accessing it, and what are
they doing with that data.
And CASB is the new security
vector that's protecting it.
And CloudLock has been working
with Google since 2007,
protecting Google
Drive environments.
We protect SaaS, PaaS,
and IaaS applications,
and protect the user's data and
apps within these applications.
Hodie and Steve mentioned
some of the challenges
before on a visibility
level, and I
want to talk a little bit
about some of the challenges
that we had on a security level.
So what we did was we applied
CloudLock's User Behavior
Entity Analytics to Team Drive.
And so for simplicity's
sake, let's take company
ABC and their finance team.
So the finance team's
files are company assets.
They're not personal.
And before, the finance teams
files were attached to a user,
and sharing was was based
on specific names, which
can be prone to error.
Another thing that happened
was getting visibility
over what content was in these
files and classifying them.
So files could reside
in multiple drives,
and you could use CloudLock's
DLP policies to classify them,
but you still had
sensitive information
distributed across many users.
And to get the big picture
view for company ABC,
you had to take the
sum of all their files
and their sensitive
information to get an overview.
With Team Drive,
this is changed.
You can specify a container.
You can label a container and
put a specific team around it.
So what we're doing now
is, the finance team,
all they need to do is
establish a circle of trust
and now the sharing
is centralized.
And the focus now is to make
sure that our circle of trust
doesn't get violated.
And we can use CloudLock
to monitor that container.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to monitor all the user
activities for the finance
files, and we can
have a new confidence
in knowing that ABC's
finance documents are
in one specific location.
And what's notable here is
once data categorization is
established, and
you've established
your circle of trust,
companies can now
put sensitive information in
the cloud and have it contained
and actively monitor it.
So what is monitor
contain and visibility?
What does that all mean?
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to actively monitor the
team's activities and Team
Drive, and then detect
for nonmember access.
We can also detect for Team
Drive membership changes
in case a nonmember gets access
to the sensitive information
and we can see what
actions they have taken
and what access they've had.
On top of that, we can
actively receive notifications
when a violation does occur.
Google does a great
job with security.
However, to be the
most secure, you
need to take a layered
approach, and this
is one additional layer to
add to your security stack.
At CloudLock, we serve some
of Google's largest enterprise
clients, so we've had
some pretty complex use
cases to work through.
I want to tell you a little
bit about that today.
So two examples of
challenges that we've had.
The first one is around
the definition of a user.
In CloudLock, when
you're creating a policy,
everything sort of revolves
around the user and the actions
that user takes.
So we had to reevaluate what
an owner means when we're
looking at actions
that people are taking
and what that means
for policy enforcement.
The second challenge
that we came across
was to get a full picture
of you, which you'll
need to do if you're
securing your environment,
is you need to be able
to look at all the Team
Drives within that environment.
And when we first
started working together,
there was no way to do that.
It was impossible.
So we worked with
Hodie and Steve
to actually create
an administrator API
so that we could look at all
Team Drives in an environment.
So just some things to
consider when you are working
with the Team Drive API.
Security should
always be a priority.
However, the user
experience is also
very critical, and
negatively impacting
that user experience can
force users and companies
to seek alternative solutions.
Some cloud applications make
you put a proxy or a gateway
in front of the solution in
order to protect and enhance
security.
And because Google takes
an API-first mentality,
it makes it very easy for
our customers and vendors
like us to work with Google.
It's been great
working with the team.
They've been very responsive
to us and our questions
around the API, and we're
really excited to release
this [INAUDIBLE] for Team
Drive because our customers are
very interested in moving
over to Team Drive,
and now we're able to
continue and extend
our security to the Team Drive.
CloudLock's
cybersecurity solution,
because it's an
API-first mentality,
is very easy to
deploy, implement,
and it gets you up and
running within minutes to help
accelerate the use of cloud.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
HODIE MEYERS: So Team Drive's
all about collaboration.
One of our favorite new apps
in the space of collaboration
is LumApps, and we
have Elie here today
with us to tells us how
they're using Team Drives.
ELIE MELOIS: Thank you.
Hi, everyone.
My name is Elie Melois and
I am the co-founder and CTO
of LumApps.
LumApps is the only
corporate and social portal
recommended by Google, and it's
fully integrated with G Suite.
LumApps is everything you need
to go to work in one place
and our goal is to make
sure that you will never
need your old intranet again.
LumApps is a social,
mobile, and smart intranet
to connect and
engage all employees.
It brings all your
internal communications
in a central hub, corporate
news, business applications,
including G Suite, and
social collaboration.
It's built on top of G Suite
and integrates with Directory,
Groups, Drive, Gmail,
Calendar, Sites, and much more.
And we are proud
to have a team 100%
dedicated to the
Google Cloud Platform.
LumApps is now used
all over the world
by Google customers who
want to make the most out
of G Suite and
especially Team Drives.
For instance, we have
a customer, Dalkia,
who will be deploying
Team Drives very soon.
Dalkia is an energy
company, a leader in Europe,
with more than 13,000
employees on G Suite.
We [? embolden ?] them two
years ago from their old custom
made intranet and had to
move more than 1,000 pages
to LumApps and thousands of
documents to Google Drive.
And we now serve more than
10,000 pages every day
for them.
And even with these impressive
numbers of pages and employees,
LumApps currently has
an 80% satisfaction rate
on the quality of the site.
However, they wanted to simplify
the permissions management
on the drive assets,
and they also
wanted to centralize the
ownership of all the files
that are put on the intranet.
And then, come Teams Drives.
As lot of Google products,
Drive is deeply integrated
in LumApps.
And today, we are
proud to announce
that the LumApps Drive features
now fully support Team Drives.
From a technical perspective,
the journey was a pleasant one
as the Team Drive
team was motivated
to make sure the
API is backwards
compatible and
well-documented and all teams
worked well together.
So we only add to make our
integrations Team Drive aware.
So at LumApps we assembled a
team of two software engineers
who corroborated with the
Team Drive experts at Google
and they remain available 24/7.
And we are especially
grateful for [? Birken ?]
and [INAUDIBLE]
involvements, as well
as are recommended for G Suite
team support with [INAUDIBLE].
They helped us
with documentation
and provided assistance
on the few hiccups
we discovered with the API.
So now let's focus on how we
solved our customers' issues,
including Dalkia's.
First, in LumApps,
we have widgets
to embed and browse Team
Drives directly on any site.
So these widgets are also
used for basic operation,
like uploading files, creating
folders, moving files, and all
of this in an effort to
encourage the usage of Drive
all over the company.
Next, in the search
engine, what we do
is that we aggregate data
from the sites, the user
directory, events, from
calendar, emails from Gmail.
And so we also plugged the
search engine into Team Drives
so users can quickly
find information
from all their corporate data.
And finally, all
team communities
are a perfect fit
for Team Drive.
They offer a place for
a team to share ideas,
best practices to
manage a project,
and so employees
can ask questions.
They can share
files, plan events
in a dedicated and fully
managed Team Drive and calendar.
So the Team Drive
is automatically
accessible to all
community members,
and permissions are
synchronized as soon as you add
the team members in LumApps.
And this is a big relief
for our customer, Dalkia,
as they can now focus on
collaboration and content
creation.
Well, if you want to
know more about LumApps,
you can meet with
us at our booth,
it's E12 at the
[? Moscone. ?] Or you
can attend our customer
testimonial tomorrow
with Veolia at 2:30 PM.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
STEVE BAZYL: Great.
Thanks, Elie.
As you can see, Team
Drives and the Drive API's
already allowing
our partners to add
a lot of valuable new services.
But of course, we're
really excited about stuff
that we haven't even seen yet
in terms of new use cases,
and we're really excited to
see what people come up with.
HODIE MEYERS: Yes, one
of those forward looking
and completely
new use cases will
be presented here by Salman.
Salman, tell us all about it.
SALMAN SUHAIL: Thank you.
Thank you very much, Hodie.
So my name is Salman Suhail.
I'm a Senior Product Manager
at Slack on the platform team
there, and I'm super
excited to be here today.
So at Slack-- and
everyone in this room
is pretty aware that there's
a massive shift happening
in the way that
work is happening
and the way that businesses
are operating their software
across the world.
People are actively
moving to the cloud
or have already moved
completely to the cloud.
The number of tools
that you're using
and the software you're
using to accomplish work
is expanding every single day.
And companies are trying
to react and figure out
how they're going to deal
with this explosion of tools
and this consumerization of
the enterprise software space.
At Slack, we're taking
a very hard look
at the shifting dynamic.
And specifically how we can
get groups and teams of people
fluidly, dynamically,
and efficiently
working together, creating
a more transparent,
and at the end of the day,
the most important thing
is a more powerful
and a more efficient
work environment for you,
the people who are actually
accomplishing work.
So our mission here is to make
people's working lives simpler,
more pleasant, and more
productive at work.
That is what we're trying to
do every single day at Slack.
And on the platform team,
our specific team's goal
is to combine the
tools and the software
that you're using
every single day
and bring them into the
place that the conversations
around the work that's
happening is there already.
So what that really looks like
in practice means that instead
of having a contact switch
between multiple accounts,
and multiple tabs, and multiple
browser windows, multiple Mac
spaces, and maybe even
multiple different OS types,
you can now pull
all of that software
directly into Slack, seamlessly
integrating the conversations
you are already having
with the work that you're
attempting to get done.
So what does that
really mean in practice?
Say I'm a product manager.
I'm having a conversation
with my sales
team about a specific client.
I don't meet with
clients every single day,
so maybe I don't
have that context.
Within the conversation,
I can directly
pull all the information
about this client.
Who they are, who their account
rep is, are we green, yellow,
red with them, what's the
next conversation we're
going to have with them,
directly into the conversation
so I don't need to jump and
get disturbed and be pulled out
of context and multitask.
What if I want to check the
status of my support tickets
because my fancy,
automated standing desk
won't go up and down anymore?
What if I wanted to reach out to
my help desk team and be like,
hey, can we get someone
to come check this out?
I can do that
directly within Slack
without having to go
to another system,
because there are enough
systems that are out there.
And most importantly,
what I'm super
excited to talk
about today, is what
if you wanted to
share and collaborate
on the docs and sheets
and slides that you
have within Google Drive?
What if you wanted to do that?
Is it necessary to go somewhere
else to manage those things?
No.
We're really excited
with some of the work
that we're doing, to
pull all of that work
directly into Slack so that we
can connect the powerhouse that
really is Google Drive with the
work that is happening inside
of Slack.
And it's the reason we're so
excited about Team Drives,
because it takes Google
Drive beyond the domain
and creates these
groups of people
who are attempting to accomplish
and move work together.
And more often than not,
those groups of people
understand the
context with which
those files need to be
shared and those files
need to be discussed.
So going into that more
micro view of those groups
is something that's
super powerful.
Now, Slack and G Suite, we've
been integrated since day one.
So day one, Slack came out,
this has always been involved.
We managed document importing,
indexing, search, and discovery
directly into Slack.
Simply by pasting
that link in there,
it automatically becomes
discoverable and searchable
within Slack already.
But of course, we're
not stopping there.
We have a very large
partnership with Google.
We have a bunch of new things
that are coming out in 2017.
Today I'm going to focus just
on the Team Drives use case.
And the reason for
that is because we
know at Google, who
takes security probably
like more close to heart than
anyone else, and at Slack,
that when teams come
together to work
there's a whole
bunch of other issues
that begin to become a problem.
We're talking about permissions.
We're talking about security.
We're talking about
user management.
We're talking about contractors
or freelancers who might come
in temporarily join your team.
These all become
massive problems,
and as your company
grows and scales
and as you begin to pull in
customer data and PII data,
the escalation
policies are on all
of these become more important
for us to be able to manage.
So firstly, just
at the Drive level,
you'll be able to provision new
Slack teams and users directly
from Google Drive.
What that means is your users,
your teams, your accounts,
they all get completely
synchronized between these two
disconnecting
platforms, making sure
that the people who
are on one always
exist [? and ?] the people
who are on the other.
So if you're already managing
your user base through Google
Drive, you won't have to involve
any other software applications
to automatically
pull that into Slack.
You can do that
directly from Google.
It's super amazing.
But if we zoom in on
that a little bit,
and this is the thing that I'm
more excited to talk about,
once that is done, you'll be
able to connect Slack channels
directly into Team Drives.
So what does that mean?
Members of a channel
can automatically
become members of
the Team Drive.
Any file that you're
discussing and sharing
with your colleagues
in that channel
can automatically be uploaded
into your Team Drive,
and then as people leave either
the company or the channel
or the project, those files
will be maintained on that Team
Drive so that you can
ensure that you never
have any kind of document loss.
Now, there is a lot of things
that we're talking about here.
There's Google Drive,
there's Team Drives,
there's Slack Teams, and
there are Slack Channels.
So if we try to take that apart
and make this a little bit more
real, what does
that actually mean?
I'm sure that most
people here have
an HR department, let's hope.
And the HR department is
probably generally getting
questions about what
benefits do I have,
what health insurance can I
sign up for, where's the latest
form for PTO days off.
And I'm sure that this HR
team is constantly being like,
oh, where is the document?
Here's the document.
Oh, I actually don't have
access to that document.
Can you please
share that document?
The number of times
that conversation
back and forth happens in a
platform like Slack is just--
the seconds that
are being wasted
are moments that
your brain is having
to switch contacts going
to this other thing
and set up the permissions to
make sure this individual can
get access to that file.
Now, because we can sync
the channel directly
with the Team
Drive, what it means
is we can set read-only
permissions on this Team Drive.
Anyone who accesses
the channel and is
interested in the
Benefits questions
automatically gets
read-only access
to all of these files
in the Team Drive.
It will be available
in their search.
It will be available in
their Google Drive UI.
And then when they leave
this HR Benefits channel,
you can assume
that they probably
don't have any HR Benefits
questions at the moment,
so they'll automatically
be removed from the files
that they don't need
to have access to.
Now, that's an
interesting use case,
but let's say we wanted to make
this a little bit more real.
I'm sure that a lot
of companies are
having really interesting
business development
partnerships--
conversations that
are happening.
In fact, there are
probably a couple
of companies in
this room today that
are having conversations
with each other
about potential partnerships.
That's how businesses
move forward.
But those partnerships
conversation
needs to be kept really quiet.
They need to be
kept very hush hush.
And you want to have a very
strong amount of control
in terms of who has
searched discovery
access to these documents
and who can go and see them
as well.
So let's say we're talking
about the Slack and Google
partnership.
We could create a channel
that was specifically
tied to this Slack and
Google relationship.
We could create a
Team Drive where
we have all of our legal
documents but also just
like our product
development conversations
in that Team Drive.
And now as anyone who
joins the channel just
called Google Partnerships
automatically gets access
to all of those documents.
It will appear within
their Drive UI.
their Slack search.
And if they were to
leave that project,
we could automatically
say, well,
anything that you
worked on, we want
to keep those documents here,
we want new team members to be
able to discover those files.
But you're no longer
on the project,
so your access
should be revoked.
All of that can
now happen as easy
as it is to join or
leave a Slack channel.
Some absolutely amazing
things with Team Drive.
I guess the thing that
we're excited with not
only is that Team Drive
has been announced,
but that all of those APIs
around those permissions
and security settings
that we would need
to be able to implement
something on the Slack side,
Google's opened up.
And that amount of control
is just incredibly powerful.
We have a bunch of things
going live in 2017 together.
We're really excited for
the Team Drives work.
Congratulations, Steve and Hodie
for going into [? GA ?] today.
And thank you very much.
STEVE BAZYL: Thanks, Salman.
To recap, Team
Drives is expanding
Drive with new capabilities
to better serve
the needs of teams.
Apps that wish to
use Team Drives do
need to make some changes.
And as you've seen,
we have partners
who've already gone
through this partner
to add support for Team
Drives to their products.
And starting today, the APIs are
available for you to integrate
with your products as well.
HODIE MEYERS: Yeah,
as [INAUDIBLE] said,
he mentioned this
morning in the keynote,
there are a lot more exciting
things coming to Drive today.
So I encourage everyone
interested in Drive
to also attend the talk
this afternoon at 1:20.
It's called "Google Drive-- the
enterprise-ready alternative
to on-prem fileshares and
legacy content management."
STEVE BAZYL: It's a mouthful.
HODIE MEYERS: It's over there
in [? Salon ?] 8, the big room.
And I think will be
very exciting too
if you interested in Drive.
[MUSIC PLAYING]